Right now, Grant's booth area at the Expo is 10 feet wide by 15 feet long. That
gives him a total area of 150 feet squared. Since area is just length times
width, which is 10 times 15. Now this whole slingshot game is taking up a ton of
space. In fact, he's already way outside his boundaries in terms of where the
ball is ending up. He's also worried that if people throw really poorly, they're
going to hit people in other booths. That would definitely not be good marketing
for Grant's Gleaming Glasses. The person in charge of the Expo told Grant that
he can, in fact, expand the space that he is in under one condition. He has to
increase his dimensions by the same amount In both directions, if he's going to
make this any bigger. For now, I'm going to call that link that we're going to
add on, x. Grant, ambitious as always, wants to double the area of his booth.
That way he'll have 300 square feet of space to do whatever he wants with. The
question is, how much does he need increase these dimensions by? What does x
need to equal to make this happen?